so what do you think like feminists are  really fighting for in 2022 because i  just like genuinely bottom of my heart i  i feel like as a woman i'm not oppressed  at all i don't think there's anything  stopping i'm in a very male dominated  sector of youtube and i think being a  woman's an advantage not a disadvantage  your subscribership keeps going up and  up and up yeah like i i honestly i've  always been in like male dominated  fields fields i worked in sales and i my  mom was also in a male dominated field  and we've always said no it's an  advantage um because you stand out more  okay um so i just  i can't think of anything like any  rights that i don't have in 2022. well  if we look at what's going on now  especially in like a couple of states  like south and west word at least in the  u.s  um there's a lot of  bodily autonomy issues that i think like  that so abortion yeah things like that  exactly